on ne sécurise pas comme il le faudrait
les manifestations
le résultat une voiture brûlée des
images qui ont fait le tour du monde
je vous le dis c'est plusieurs milliards
qui se sont envolés dans cette voiture
plusieurs milliards de retombées
économiques elle a fait le tour du monde
cette image là on a eu l'année dernière
les attentats terroristes
donc c'est catastrophique c'est
catastrophique pour l'économie française
parce que qu'est-ce que les caisses
qu'un étranger se dit je vous rappelle
que rien que sur l'île de france les
retombées économiques du tourisme et 21
milliards 30 % de moins à cause des
attentats
cette année qu'est ce que cette image va
redonner encore quelques places et nous
mêmes parce que on est on se met dans
l'incapacité on ne veut pas sécurisé on
met pas les moyens pour sécuriser une
manifestation c'est à dire qu'on laisse
faire